frère tu vas avoir une Chine à toi si tu
perds pas 18 kg pendant la je m'appelle
pas noun frère celui-là frère non mais
tu Rous frère il
doit il do frère il doit il doit
transpirer
la maman tu connais la transpiration
sale arrête parce que il y a deux types
de transpiration tu vois celle c'est la
sale tu sais avec le pull en laine et
quand il les pull il va coller un peu
arête mais pourquoi vous dit tjours
qu'il est sale mais non il est très
propre voilà et ses chiens sont sales
voilà lui il est très propre est nickel
quoi c'est vrai vra oui j'ai fait du
Gol nickel même la balle est
ressortie rien à
dire je dis rien à dire Ren JeanMichel
Jean-Michel mer ça va ou très bienah
jusqu'à quelques secondes ça allait oui
bah j'étaé choqué par vre fr j'ai vu son
cul on est où là c'esti qui c'est vous
qui c'est qui s
non mais rellez-vous arrêtez d'applaudir
c'est
ridicule vous dites saloperies to
dépêche c'est vous quiz prononcé la
phrase moi ch
horrible oh là là mais le rard de oh là
là mais les chaussures mais quelle
horreur ilens que ça
verit
baset ch va faire un bowling
non mais c'est horrible mais quelle
horreur ce mec e oh parle pas au public
elle m'interroge je réponds t'interroge
pour savoir o poless c'est vilain
chaussur ah ben je suis content d'aller
dans à côté tiens il y a toutes les
danseuses Revens rev reviens reviens
rens reviens
rens bon aujourd'hui on a un petit
spectacle en début d'émission à 19h59
Gill Verdes la tête de pervers mon frère
quel racera le gars ouis ah mais tu es
horrible mais tu dégoûtes les gens
dégoûes en fait tu dégoûtes les gens
dégoûtes les gens donc je vais me mettre
là vos il est pas ressorti Jean-Michel
laisse tu sais je vais te dire il sera
mieux là-bas euh il sera plus utile pour
un petit spectacle pour démarrer
l'émission il y a Clara Morgan qui est
notre invité son spectacle s'appelle au
7e B c'est juste après le
6 je crois que mais tu arrivrives
directement l'ascenseur arrive
directement là sur est tous les mardis à
la nouvelle Ève jusqu'au 24 février et
on est dans toute la France alors je
sais pas du tout ce que c'est j'ai pas
vu les répèes mais en tout cas c'est une
surprise et je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
de tu as pris la meilleure place mon
[Rires]
salot qu-ce qu'il est con là le jou de
guingan là c'est lourd
de allez applaudissement pour
claragan
lorsque je suis arrivé dans la
capitale je rêvais de devenir une femme
fatale ma JEE buvais pas je ne me
droguais pas et n'avais aucun complexe
je suis beaucoup trop normal ça me vexe
[Musique]
je ne suis pas parisienne ça me gêne ça
me gêne je ne suis pas dans le fond
c'est naant c'est na aucune bizarerie ça
me nuit ça me nuit pas la moindre
affectation je ne suis pas dans le temps
je ne suis pas végétarienne ça me gêne
ça me gne je ne suis pas car ça me met
dans l'embarras je ne suis pas file
c'est débile c'est débile je ne suis pas
MLS je sens comment FA
[Musique]
et puis j'ai fa connaissance d'un groupe
d'amis vivant en communauté dans le même
lit comme je ne buvais pas je ne me
droguais pas une mais aucun complexe je
crois qu'ils en sont restés tout
[Musique]
perplex je ne suis
pas BL je ne suis pas ça me nuit ça
me nuit je ne suis pas masochiste existe
ça existe pour réussir mon destin je
vais voir le médecin je ne suis pas
schizophrène ça me gêne ça me gne je ne
suis pas hstérique ça se complique ça se
complique me dit le psychanalyste que
c'est triste que c'est triste je lui dis
je désespère je n'ai pas le goût
[Musique]
pervers mais si mais dit le docteur en
se
rabillant d'après ce premier essai c'est
encourage
si vous ne buvez pas vous ne vous
droguez pas et n'avez aucun complexe
vous avez une obsession c'est
[Musique]
le depuis je suis à la mode je me rôe je
me rôe dans les lits de Saint-Germain
c'est divin c'estin je fais partie de
l'élite ça va vite ça va vite et je me
donne avec choix tout en faisant du ha
je vois les filmesépouvantes je
m'envente je m'enfente en serant très
fort la main du foisin du foisin mais sa
chante originale je cavale je cavale
j'assume ma lipido tout en faisant du
vélo maintenant je suis parisienne et je
me surmène et je me surmène et je
connais la détresse et le car et le
stress bientôt à l'écologie je ici je
ici et loin de la pollution je vais
tendre mes moutons et loin de la
pollution je vais tendre mes moutons mes
moutons mes moutons mes moutons
[Musique]
bravo merci Clara
Morgan tous les mardis à la nouvelleve
jusqu'au 24 février en tourné en toute
la France Merci Clara et merci à à ton
équipe merci merci beaucoup
merci
merci merci
merci ah là là ça va les ché JeanMichel
tu dégoûtes mais je sais pas tu dégoûtes
excuse-moi de te dire ça franchement
c'était fantastiquechement j'ai vu le
théâtre du bolchoy c'est la rigolade à
côé sais pas mais pourquoi il est lourd
comme ça g ça t'a plu j'ai adoré par
contre on a pété un micro non non non il
est là j'ai juste non non non je connais
c'est bon g merci Gill en tout cas merci
tu peux partir avec le micro s'il te
plaît merci tu es bien aimable merci
Clara alors c'est c'est c'est le le
spectacle ça fait maintenant combien de
temps que tu fais ton 2015 maintenant
alors écoute ça a commencé il y a 6 ans
l'histoire du cabaret et j'avais
vraiment envie de créer un spectacle qui
soit une Hae à la femme entouré de
femmes des acrobates des femmes
puissantes des femmes fortes des
poôleuses et j'ai réussi ça en 6 ans
d'expérience et pas encore
d' quelque chose et la 7e année et bien
c'est vrai que les planètes se sont
alignées j'ai mon spectacle au 7e
évidemment pour le jeu de mot mais il y
a SEP femmes en scène SEP chansons live
que je chante SEP tableaux et c'est vrai
que tout tourne autour de 7 et ça me ça
me plaît parce que ça me ça m'a rassuré
pour sur ma place ça m'a donné confiance
en moi et j'ai senti comme un un signe
avec tous ces stes qui me disaient vas-y
fais-le tu peux le faire maintenant tu
es assez grande et je suis hyper Fiè
parce qu'on a une belle tournée c'est
vrai de 50 dates on passe un peu partout
et tous les mardis à la nouvelle 4 fév
etour dans la France
C
dans